jeff decimos segundo día de ofensiva
rusa nos dirigimos al sur hacia las
zonas afectadas por los primeros
bombardeos básicos es una ciudad en
donde hay despliegues permanentes de
soldados un objetivo estratégico una
prioridad para las fuerzas rusas
estos son los efectos concretos de la
invasión militar de rusia en ucrania
estamos en la ciudad de basil kof a 40
kilómetros al sur de la capital
ucraniana y lo que ven en las imágenes
es una escuela que fue alcanzada por un
misil ruso una destrucción total de este
edificio además todavía hay a mis pies
en libros escolares abrigos por lo que
podemos imaginar la fuerza del impacto
sobre este establecimiento
grant gustaría pienso en todos mis
amigos que estudiaron en este colegio
pienso en el viejo señor que trabajaba
aquí
es verdaderamente atroz para todas estas
personas y para los niños que estaban
aquí en el ayuntamiento de basil con los
voluntarios los soldados y las fuerzas
de defensa están activos las 24 horas
del día en los sótanos viven más de un
centenar de refugiados let me la era
profesora en la escuela bombardeada
ahora se ocupa de las familias
escondidas aquí
crees que tendrás que irte en algún
momento
no de ninguna manera nos quedamos esta
es nuestra ciudad y para ir a donde
todos los que viven aquí han decidido
quedarse
no vamos a huir lucharemos tomaremos las
decisiones correctas siempre
encontraremos una manera de aguantar no
tenemos ninguna duda
llevamos cuatro días sin salir
anoche estuvo bastante tranquilo está
bien
la situación en esta ciudad refleja la
realidad ucraniana un implacable avance
ruso de una población decidida a
resistir